so I'm wearing this shirt in this review
for a reason this movie talked about the
kind of movie that this movie is silent
hail revelation is actually a sequel to
the film that came out a few years back
which I saw and wasn't very impressed
with I thought it had good production
design some disturbing elements but
overall it was just not a good movie and
when I heard that this new film was a
sequel I was kind of perplexed by that
because I really feel like enough people
have actually seen the original and I
don't think anyone's really gonna be
thinking that much about the original
going into this movie
the first Silent Hill game I played I
played the very first one for
PlayStation 1 when it came out when I
was a kid and that was terrified by it
I'll never forget there was one part
where I was walking through this hallway
in the game and I was sitting there in
my room it was dark it was like 3 a.m. I
had this huge window looking out into
the forest okay there's this little
thing that just squeaks in there
and I remember I was like this little
teenage kid I just jumped out of my seat
I'll never forget that okay now that was
over the first scary games I ever played
so I appreciate the games you know I
understand what they're trying to do and
in that sense I feel good because I can
talk to you about this movie sensibly
because I understand the source material
just like with Resident Evil love the
games don't like the movies movie starts
out Sean Bean and his adoptive daughter
they're moving from place to place
trying to get away from police people
are looking for them and the daughters
having these intense dreams about Silent
Hill and Sean Bean keeps telling her
don't go there eventually people from
Silent Hill come and take Sean Bean back
to Silent Hill and now the daughter has
to go find him along with a hunky
schoolboy that she goes to school with
there's like this medallion thing that
she has to get another piece forward to
connect to be able to defeat something
it's basically a video game which makes
sense since the source material is a
video game however the source material
is actually good it's not a good movie
it has good performances I will give it
that Sean Bean is not bad in this film
I've always liked Sean being a lot the
main girl in the film actually ain't
that bad either
other than that the performances are
kind of weak in my opinion it has an
impressive visual will look at times
there are some disturbing elements to
the film there is one good scene with
this spider mannequin thing other than
that this movie is pretty much a jumbled
mess now there's a lot of problems I
have this movie and let me explain one
of them the darkness alright when night
falls in Silent Hill and all these
things come out and they can kill you
throughout the entire first act this
movie the girl has dreams about this
place okay but you recognize that there
they cannot interact with the real world
she's just dreaming about these events
then slowly there's this character
looking for that she's terrified of he
he stands around and to be honest it was
actually getting very comical I was
laughing a lot some of the scares in the
first part of this movie there's this
Private Eye looking for all of a sudden
the darkness starts to permeate the real
world some guy gets his fingers chopped
off and everything and there's these
things after her in the real world now
Sean Bean keeps telling her don't go to
Silent Hill it's dangerous do not go to
Silent Hill you will die if these things
can somehow interact with the real world
what's the point of staying away from
Silent Hill they can come into the real
world and screw everything up and she
actually asks her friend do you think
there's a difference between dreams and
reality of course there's a difference
honey one of them takes place when
you're asleep and unconscious the other
one happens when you're walking around
in the real world
also in this movie there's like this one
character this big guy with like this
giant sword in this pyramid like head
who follows the main girl around helping
her at times and you have no idea why
why is he doing this why is there
suddenly some epic fight amongst a giant
like Ring of Fire with the with the main
two bosses basically of this movie
there's a strange element where a cammeo
happens from the first film she's like
oh I got the daughter she's right here
and and then Shawn being hugged the
daughter okay oh she's real yay now wait
a second how do you suddenly get back in
Silent Hill how's the daughter back what
was that vision what the hell just
happened like I don't understand
sometimes what is going on in this movie
it's very very poorly written it's
absurdly written actually so there's
just one famous actor who I won't give
away he has this cameo and then he turns
into some kind of beast or creature or
something and he dies in the most
easiest possible way you could ever
think of it's just like there's your
wound right there okay shoot it it's
basically like a boss on a video game it
wow the 3d in the film at times was good
and then at times it was abysmal like
there were certain shots where it looked
fine but in there were shots where the
glare from lights that were in the
background actually overtook everything
in the foreground and made my eyes
completely cross I mean anyone who
looked at me won't just see me go oh I
do these reviews for films like this
because they're fun to film but you guys
know this movie is just it's not good
stay away from it please if you liked
the first film maybe just rent this when
it comes out that's my suggestion I'm
gonna give Silent Hill revelation a
d-minus
thanks for watching guys and as always
if you liked this review then you can
right here and get stuck menage
[Music]